[Music]
if you're a gamer in Korea you've
probably spent time at a PC bang these
are 24 hour video game cafes where
diehards play for hours on end this
jobless 1j he speaks English really well
you've seen me play video games online
you said yes do you think I'm good kind
of okay what do you really mean by that
no no show me what's the most popular
game in Korea startled I see Starcraft
and you can click on him with your right
mouse yeah and those herbs will go kill
him kill him kill him kill him kill him
am i doing a good job yeah so now what
do I do I just wait yeah you know what
maybe you should just play this game and
I should go find a place to have alcohol
good what's the longest you spend in a
PC bang 14 hours you spent 14 hours in a
PC bang those because I was drunk it
didn't have anywhere to go so I played
games worth 14 hours is that why the
seats are plastic he just knew your name
while you're playing so I'm never
urinary well it's fine
[Music]
I'm told that Koreans spend so much time
playing these games yet you can order
snacks what's this one called you know
this is squid chips squid chips these
are chips that taste like squid okay is
that a popular snack here right you just
described most foods good BJ one one day
oh one day I'm sorry I'm high on squid
chip what's this right here
those are King shells King shells yeah
what does that mean so you know like a
shellfish like a king shellfish so
basically you guys take whatever you
just find on the beach at low tide
okay oh my god what is this it's a egg
dipped in soy sauce why would you
I just seems like an egg is not
something that you would sell as like a
like it's like an M&M packaging and then
there's this snack can you tell us what
this is right here it's called silkworm
pupa when isoform makes a cocoon you
take the silk away you boil it with soy
sauce and you get it is this something
that you enjoy
yeah I kind of like it okay okay
no you just one yeah really yeah that
was joyless yeah
victory you won it can we change to a
game that I might have some chance of
understanding yes that was what we in
America call a [ __ ] show for me it's a
Korean counter-strike so you would be
shooting other people
no behind this game
you're playing videogames it looks like
you work at a bank
[Applause]
I'd like an aisle seat now we can begin
the game yes or is this just give us the
privilege of writing 7,000 other lines
of code well I guess there will be no
more typing unless you want to insult
someone on the game what are common
insults in Korea they talk about you
know your family a lot really yeah
mean things about your family very mean
things about your it seems like such a
polite culture so we're using an m16
rifle right now no code you got like
ak-47 or a sniper so what kind of gun
would you like I think my best weapon is
this music
I think that's gonna ward off any foe
who come to my way where do I go you're
going to the end go do it this way okay
then why w ok w w what do i do wrong i
got killed that quickly
you just hit took us about an hour to
get loaded in this game
what's happening why is that woman we're
looking up her skirt and she's dancing
what has happened what is this that was
the weirdest episode of Teletubbies I've
ever seen so anyway I can't onto other
people yes why don't you write your
family eat soy eggs rotten soy eggs your
mother does not prepare squid properly
they're ignoring me
yeah they're ignoring you I am Conan
O'Brien and I'm playing this game right
now
oh is that so what I'm gonna call you so
egg I says you're really not funny then
say that's proof that this is Conan
O'Brien
you